for most of our lives
we're hard at work we're up till
midnight in the library
studying for a degree we're learning a
trade building a business
writing a book we have hardly a moment
to ourselves
we don't even ask whether we're
fulfilled it's simply obvious
that this is the bit that has to hurt we
fall asleep
counting the weeks until the end and
then
finally one day slightly unexpectedly
the end arrives through slow and steady
toil
we have achieved what we've been seeking
for years
the book is done the business is sold
the degree certificate is on the wall
people around us cheer and lay on a
party we might even take
a holiday and that is when for many of
us
a supreme unease is liable to descend
the beach is beautiful the sky is
flawless
there's a scent of lemon in the air from
the orchard we've got nothing unpleasant
to do
we can read lol play and dordle
why then are we so flat disoriented
and perhaps slightly tearful why we
so scared the mind works in deceptive
ways
in order to generate the momentum
required to induce us to finish
any task our mind pretends that once the
work is done
it will finally be content it will
accept reality as it is
it will stop its restless persecutory
questions
it won't throw up random unease or
guilty feelings
it will be on our side but whether by
intent or coincidence our mind is not
in any way well suited to honoring such
promises
it turns out to be sharply opposed to
and even endangered by
states of calm and relaxation
it can manage them at best for a day or
so
and then with cold rigor it will be on
its way again
with worries and questions it will ask
us once more
to account for ourselves to ask what the
point of us
is to doubt whether we're worthy or
decent
to question what right we have to exist
once hard work ends there is nothing to
stop
our melancholy minds from leading us to
the edge of an abyss
we'd been able to resist so long as our
heads were down
we start to feel that no achievement
will ever
in fact be enough that nothing we can do
will make a difference
that little is as good as it should be
that we are tainted by some kind of
primordial
guilt of being alive that others around
us are
far more noble and able than we will
ever be
that the blue sky is oppressive and
frightening and that doing nothing
is actually the hardest thing we've ever
attempted to do
it's as though deep down our mind knows
that the ultimate fate of the planet is
to be absorbed by the sun
in seven and a half billion years and
that everything we do is therefore
vain and futile against a cosmological
sense of time and space
we know that we are puny and irrelevant
apparitions
we haven't been so much busy as
protected from despair
by the use of deadlines punishing
schedules
work trips and late night conference
calls
but now with the achievement secured
there is no defense left
against the might of existential terror
it's just
us and in the skies above the light of a
billion billion
dying stars there are no more 8 30 am
meetings no more revision notes
no more chapter deadlines to distract us
from our metaphysical irrelevance
we should of course be a bit kinder on
ourselves
rather than putting ourselves through
the infinitely demanding process of
idling we should be self-compassionate
enough
to keep setting ourselves one slightly
irrelevant
but well camouflaged challenge after
another
and do our very best to pretend that
these matter
hugely and we should leave no sizable
gaps between them
our work exists to protect us from a
brutal
sense of despair and anxiety we should
make sure
we never stop having tasks to do
and never make that most reckless of all
moves
retire or embark on that next most
reckless step
taking a long holiday
how to think more effectively is a book
about how to optimize our minds
so that they can more regularly and
generously produce the sort of insights
and ideas we need
to fulfill our potential and achieve the
contentment we deserve
you